she's a dying me though mmm she's [__]
Wooden Nickel yes I don't know man
I wouldn't give you two cents for her
attitude that's for sure but what do I
know you know I'm just an accomplished
young man with a [__] nice
[Laughter]
hey who got [__] over worse Lance
Armstrong or Joe exotic that's a good
debate bro rose
oh we have it oh is that is that what
King you're singing it's a debate club
Oh Glenn it's Armstrong first Joey my
boy Michael Rapaport uh Mike the rap the
rapper Larry Bird's evil twin this is
Michael Rapaport aka the pandemic Pied
Piper aka the Swingle man for the debate
club the king and the sting he said did
you guys think
Joe exotic from the tiger King
documentary series on Netflix should be
in prison what do you guys think
personally I think he's the fall guy I
don't think you should be in prison what
do you guys think Oh everybody's good
hope everybody's safe and hopefully I'll
see everybody in person soon my brother
happy nice we did exotic J's brownies
really yeah here's Anshu with jordan now
oh my do you know about them all the
animals is there a real cat on it that's
yeah that's that right there's that
that's that cloud leopard this is
Panther that's a zebra that one of them
killed Dan you got your official tiger
here oh and look at that lemur
backstraps off bro that [__] is
beautiful dude
damn your Jordans ein Williams or Joe
exotic let's go Joey I love pigs
dude this is those are beautiful and
this is a good question man from Michael
Rapaport happy 50th Michael my favorite
people on the planet yes Michael
Rapaport he's definitely a real loud
mouth dude he is I'll say this man he's
definitely he's one of my favorite
sports people to listen to because he's
like he's like the white Stephen a Smith
really he should have his own show yeah
yeah why doesn't he had that he don't
mean him we're gonna do our own sports
show on Fox really it's gonna be me and
him like Jake oh yeah and then he's just
a guy that yells yeah he's a guy that
yells at me about
but uh yeah the guy was like let's do
this and it was like completely buddy
yeah some little Muppets like yeah let's
doing well yeah put your mother in a
body bag son tell you that tiger
sanctuary yeah dude I'll say this you
know who's a real uh and I'm not gonna
say it out loud but POS time had that
tiger cut huh that Tiger cut [__] oh no
what have you seen the doc yeah yeah
what's the whole thing dude I knew about
this years before man years ago yeah I
did it you did it
oh dude ah I was watching my mouth was I
bro I've been following Joe exotic for a
while check out my Instagram like a year
and a half did a picture I just yeah he
was your boy or what no but I just know
he's been out there I got a buddy that
even worked over at UM at GW at that
place for I guess maybe two months it's
over the whole time ago
yeah have you ever been there huh you
have you ever been ever been no yeah but
people were always likes enemy you know
messages do send me pictures thank you
yeah you're not bad you look you look
like Joe exotics gayest boyfriend you
watch no his boyfriend's aren't gay
bring that dude comes in just to play
with the tiger some good-looking normal
dude six six straight whoa hey there
driving he goes how straight are easy
pretty straight bro he goes yeah when
you watch porn do you like to look at
the big dicks or the small big he's like
well the big dicks
you ain't that straight and then it it
just time elapsed and they're married
yeah and they're in the dudes [__]
them now it's like ah you know if they
were having sex bro now they were
married he was in a relationship do you
see the picture where one dudes on the
ground like is like the dude with no
teeth the meth heads on the ground like
this Jane oh no that's not James and
then they're both like and then the six
six dude in here we're just happiest
[__] yeah that little [__] dick traps
at the bottom on one knee like a [__]
they had that boy a little thirst
I set him down there dude dude well
they're bulik man a lot of beautiful men
out there yeah what was that
do you know when that was September 2018
is 2018 two years ago you were on this
Joey
Johnny yeah right there I'm surprised
you they didn't do a dot cup with you on
there dude I'm surprised in an interview
I'm not your queen up in this video
Tiger gesture or whatever maybe though
maybe they'd let me in there man dude
I'll say this though James Garretson
let's pull up a picture of James
Garretson dude is the real [__] Fink
who got up he got caught on the hot he
got he got that hot lemur and you dumb
I'm on the dark web huh yeah no I think
he got it from Joe actually I see the
one with that he looks like the owner of
the Raiders here's that [__] yeah
yeah well that little [__] snitch
just yeah that little dummy right there
dude that little [__] cinnamon roll
bro a little frickin nob he looks like
he sells Cinnabon on the dark web
yes [__] dude he looks like yawns the
Raiders he looks identical to the owner
of the Raiders right yeah if the Raider
guy just ate Cinnabons bring him up make
that [__] thirst trap lemur this guy
loves the Raiders definitely been
huffing York Peppermint Patties on the
side bright eyed dude looks like uh I
don't trust that [__] well yeah he
had that dirty lemur and that's he
didn't want to go down so they don't
look identical bro hmm come on now come
on dude I need a better picture Jason
you can't find it and it's James he's an
official employee of the u.s. you know I
have some pictures of him on my phone
really yeah I'll send you a couple you
know him huh huh
no no no he's just been texting you pics
of him he's trying to sell you a lemur
and [__] I snagged some off the dock
here we go you know what you know what I
get why you guys show him on that jet
ski with that dope rocky music
[__] they shown this dude
because they're trying to that was part
of the deal I bet hey man will like you
it will make you look like a champ
you know we just need you to uh rat
everybody out here he is probably with a
hot lobster who knows where he got that
bastard from dude he got a steno some
galley lobster right now buying a
lobster I'm just gonna cook him and eat
him that's a thing man he had that one
shady lemur and he's running that
bootleg Dollar General over there you
saw that here by himself one of the
aisles had like tricycles on one of a
mad beef jerky and that was all of the
aisles this is my store the worst front
ever dude there was definitely a lot of
drug-induced homosexuality and that's
one thing you see on this documentary
hey don't talk about it don't can we
talk about Joe exotic and his meth habit
the entire [__] time now boy has some
Slammers though his music yeah say what
you want about Joe exactly but he
creates some [__] I am her hangers
row a Slammers dude he definitely he's
that I'll talk about gay pogs either now
you know I'm saying he's kind of like he
reminds him like a um he reminds me of
somebody that works at a carnival you
know yeah the guy that runs the thing
that you hit me yeah but he had that
pistol on have you guys seen it or not
oh yeah oh really well you guys think
about it
I was just I was like okay where's the
black people Oklahoma bro he's in the
middle of Oakland Oklahoma not a title
Griffin and he's only happy and then his
brother - who's a quarter yeah yeah
brothers only a quarter so there's
literally he's allowed but there's some
question marks as how ones I haven't
one's a quarter - but yeah same parents
I wouldn't mind one of the music videos
right now oh he got some real hits oh
man what was the one where they're
feeding up the meat to the tiger Oh
husband cuz that little [__] knife
yeah hey Katie the girl who he got his
archrival not entrust Harold Raskin dude
Harrell and she killed her husband fell
to the Tigers Carol Baskin yeah to say
the full name every girl basket and he's
gonna go down there here we go
are you shared it up
[Music]
[__] inside there good man I can't
believe
[Music]
and clouded leopards back you notice how
he touch everybody slow and bass boom oh
yeah how did you do that to me college
open the Dow wardie athletic seven get
down
[__] dude it's not the kind of music you
want to listen to with your mouth open
though you know that that hi I do feel
different if you're listening with your
mouth open it feels different but carol
Baskin is a straight-up husband killer
bro that h k bro you know that [__] but
what I want to know is what do you guys
think coach corner about the
homosexuality that was in the
documentary cuz I enjoyed it I feel like
I thought it made a better story I'm not
a - bro what you're just him and his bro
oh dude that's I didn't find the man to
be gay that's all I got so nice and then
the one dude who came was like 6 6 was
like I guess I'm gay and then again time
lapse they don't tell us anything he's
married and then dude spoiler Coosh from
the Tigers killed himself
yeah blues living a lie bro he was
engage us went to pet the Tigers yeah I
mean oh they got him that's how they got
him they made him with a tiger and then
hit him with that meth cat and that dude
I guess I want to touch this cloud
leopard that bad in the suck you up Joe
now I think there might have been oral
sex I don't think that there was
full-body sex
well that mouth head was down though do
you see the tattoo he got that said
property of joe joe said joe exotic
property only right above his dick peace
i didn't read it right above his
Tigertail right and then when he broke
up went back to the tattoo artists and
got a big old bull now here we have a
couple of the images right here so we
can see what you're actually talking
about yeah give me the one where it's
those three of them and then the one
thirst trap on meth has taken a knee
like a [__] high school football
picture at the top at the top it's the
three of them there you go on the right
yeah that's that's them tiger boys
beautifulness I talk about the Detroit
Tigers either now beautiful man yeah man
I just filled him right here a lot of
frickin characters and that boy in the
bombs the picture right now now I could
see that now I feel like that's what I
felt like there wasn't any full body sex
going on I felt like it was
predominantly probably oral sex oh you
get anybody else get that no not me you
crazy you think Jose just wants all
you think Joe exotic doesn't put on the
jungle book and [__] these books I got
your my you know sweaty them boys in the
Oklahoma summers you kidding me Oh get
up on that it's hard to do meth in the
sunlight but I don't you know anything
about drugs
oh it's a winner drugs more of a summer
drug all right no I think weed and stuff
like that is more of a summer drug so
that's a nighttime drug we those you
need those uppers in the winter when you
get that seasonal affective disorder
yeah you just [__] feeding 300 time
it's hard to do a lot of blow and be out
in the Sun you know you won't see
somebody doing blowing going you know
laying out by the beach oh I didn't know
that you know I don't know my drugs well
it's fine but here these men are right
here near a field or near a corn or
something beautiful to the one guy is
pretty damn beautiful I will say that
I'm a boy on the right yeah yeah all
right marry [__] kill with these three
huh
what better dad okay sorry all right wet
better dead with these three right here
man we´d better Darrow uh joy exotic I'm
America's a boy he comes up with him
idea I can play with his Tigers all the
time I'm located marketing for the
market marketing I'm gonna go ahead and
kill the boy taking an e on the Left I
gotta kill him dude get out of here I
didn't like his that attitude and also
when she got tough he snitched on him
bro he [__] he's taking advantage of
man hey how about Joe exotics tight
[__] khakis and his [__] sticking out
right in that picture
dude get your dick out of my boy's face
and then I'm gonna go ahead and hang out
with the boy on the right and probably
just literally hang out and play Madden
or something yeah he's not like duck
hunt yeah what would you guys chat am i
off on this - what about you I don't
think you're off on that at all Wow yeah
whoo your choices be cat let's get a
female perspective here since this thing
seems predominantly homosexual who's the
best looking one cat eye best-looking
one is the guy on the right young guy on
the right I would bet him because he's
straight I would marry Oh
great except for jokes okay I don't know
I think Joey's training it was a lot of
you just seemed like a lot everything
about him seemed like reaching for
something you know yeah almost like he
seemed like a fake gay to me now done to
the head has he [__] with him Tigers
probably dunno well yeah if it's gotta
be so hard to do though but is that gave
us a gay yeah you're awesome it's pretty
special it's pretty special it's way
better than [__] just some shitty you
met yeah you're right when you're right
you're right though but I really the
homosexuality that was gone going on out
there I feel like it'd be so hard to be
gay in that hot Sun yeah okay look like
a winter sport
boys agree my snuggle with a bear Harry
dude these guys in that Oklahoma God and
the Sooners are played got time to [__]
we gotta watch the Sooners and feed
these Tigers yeah dude a lot of brave
gays out there Manning you don't know
that now will say this is definitely it
opens up a whole new breed of kind of
renegade homosexuality I feel like that
you're gonna start singing really taking
over kind of the Midwest and the upper
Upper West it's gonna be you - if you
get that zoo in Mexico it could have
been 4,200 yeah
still could be dude that's true dude
look man it's uh it's tough times man
you know very tough a lot of people
worried about debt and what their future
is gonna look like and it's easy get in
debt it's frickin hard getting out man
especially records scores a little
little sketchy like Joe exotic you want
a sketchy bro hit you some upstart
dot-com thank God for these people
that's true man now upstart if you're
not familiar it goes beyond the
traditional credit score when it
assessing your creditworthiness yes they
actually reward you based on your
education and job history in a form of a
smarter rate right so they're taking
your full life in your behavior and who
you are into context they're more than
just your credit score man yeah they
make it fast simple and easy to check
your rate since it's just a soft pull
which I'm definitely from
it won't affect your credit score then
hard poll happens if you accept your
rate yes the best part once the loan is
approved and accepted most people get
their funds the very next day at the
next day yes so you need lending this is
a place to check out over 400,000 people
have used up start to pay off credit
cards or to meet their financial goals
free yourself from the burden of higher
interest credit card debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with up start Wow see
why upstart is top ranked in the
category with a 4.9 out of 5 rating on
Trustpilot in a hurry to upstart com /k
ats to find out how low your up start
rate is check in your rate only takes a
few minutes that's upstart com /k ats up
start
oh yeah look man I will say one of the
blessings of the coronavirus time is
that you have more time to be take care
yourself yeah you do and guess what
fellas you're just laying around the
house nobody should have bushes right
now get rid of that bush man this ain't
joy get that G got that George W in your
pain I quit playing hide-and-go-seek we
did we nor let them out trim the bus
dude yeah man you got that Kurt Busch
and your pastor problem you need a
frickin trim your ass car dude you
really do man we do with manscape all
right you need to do it you need to do
with their new and improved a lot more
three-point arm when I tell you this is
premium I mean premium the battery will
last up to 90 minutes listen if it takes
you over 90 minutes to shave yo junked
you don't deserve man state yeah
everything she 90 minutes to shave your
junk dude you're an artist okay start
charging yeah no more cuts and Nick's
with the manscape lawnmower 3.0 this is
that third generation that third Jenny
trimmer that's three times the try
thought get 20% off free shipping with
the code Kay 80s at manscape calm your
balls will thank you them you can't Nick
you're nuts you need to try this out for
yourself get 20% off and free shipping
with the code Kay 80s at manscaped
dot-com 20% off free shipping cats at
manscape calm
actually there's like no cases in Mexico
coronavirus no cases and we I'm sure you
get a [__] killer deal on Crona beer
right now we only serve ya beer in a bat
suit and Bobcats and bad see here popped
a bat suit
that's triple B's I just feel like I
don't know man so many emotions go
through me when I was watching the
documentary because you feel for the the
the drug young fellows that got hooked
on the drug can we talk about his mentor
that had seven [__]
seven wives Doc anal dude [__] davon bruh
bog davon he was the real MVP he said it
means Lord right yep yeah yeah but a
curette like bog davon doc he already
has two titles and then he tells you one
of them means Lord it's a bit much yeah
that the whole thing was strange that
dude and then Joe exotic the one thing
when I couldn't [__] with him is when he
was on trial and he threw his boy under
the bus his mentor yeah he's like he's
actually killing Tigers and he [__]
puts him in a gas chamber then he burns
them oh yeah that's your boy man yeah he
said he was like they were taking tigers
and like waterboarding them and like
doing them on the right lights and stuff
like that and I'm not gonna sleep yeah
yeah tickling him he said that they were
putting glitter on their tails and
tickling him the Tigers just doing a
ball that [__] was not a lot of levels
man a lot of levels
hey what about when the girl's arm gets
a bit off bro not the best thing on TV
is that not the best of URC MTV and they
actually have the footage but my
favorite thing right arm off she's
laying there pretty calm she's a badass
bro savvy yeah bad part my favorite part
is Joe exotic why he has a [__] huh
he is like a nurse's jacket on I have no
idea where he got it he goes his office
he goes hey y'all
yeah I'll tell you straight up right now
I got to tell you something man okay so
I'm right here to hear about it
the news all right somebody just kept
the damn arm bit off over there by a
tiger all right so come back another day
or what you going give you money back
yeah yeah and they those Oklahomans
didn't give a [__] no one even budged no
look at this gangster kill the lamb man
[__] you there he is right there stay
with me stay with me he didn't really
snap in there look we really did why
does he have that jacket on though huh
why would you buy something like that
he's not a [__] pro you know you got
to grow up in a more rural area dude
everybody is a part-time EMT dude run
from dude look at that audience when he
tells them yes once you just come back
no day all right young lady got her arm
bitten off yeah back up a little bit on
that Nicola to get that little section
from them again so you got the gun I'm
Becky in the pink on this part Nicky
back up a little gun feedback you them
Tigers back up yeah lady and gentleman
port here on the news about an hour ago
we had an incident and one of the
employees stuck there on through the
cage and a tiger Toro Larry on the left
one lady just has a one jar a tiger but
Tiger Balm she's like I just I was gonna
get my Jersey side that make sense I can
give you your money back and give you a
rain check I brought my sister Fields
Jersey though god dammit bro and if
crazy for that's the one day you want to
be in the park that's finally gonna be
there some live action you'd only be at
Six Flags but nobody loses a [__]
limb bruh yeah I love that EMT jacket
though where did he get that we'll never
recover from this financially oh that's
my favorite any starts crying yeah well
it's just God here's my favorite part of
the whole documentary and never gonna
find a part about being an entrepreneur
but then I have also been like the the
main guy of the main guys star you
the main event you got to go back and
forth between businessman and sensation
and here's the other thing though did
nobody plan for this did you not think
out of all the years somebody's get
[__] their arm ripped off by the
tiger uh well yeah but of course this
happened hey about it when he ran for
president
oh yeah the balls on this man dude he's
under yeah that's the thing man I'll
tell you this I will say this one thing
I noticed about I'm I talked about the
doc men he was at he's a hard worker
he's brave he was always involved like
anytime their load and stuff on trucks
or whatever he was never not involved
agree you know and I think I think he
[__] got the worst of everything and
everyone turned against him because they
knew he had Talent and they [__] put
him in prison for 22 years
he does have some Appeals coming up but
I agree it's looking like it's not gonna
go well but my favorite when he face
times from prison and his roots were
growing out and his hairs all [__] up
I thought it looked better with the
brown hair
now that blonde
oh dude that's local that's local fair
ground blonde right there dude you can
only get that [__] color blonde out
outside of a roadie I bet you he's
thriving in prison though
oh yeah booty galore that's another
thing bro but I don't know man dude he's
such a such an interesting guy because
it's almost like he would do anything to
find somebody that cared about him or
some or to find I don't know I mean the
level he went to to make himself like
things like famous yeah like just I mean
it just never ended it like you know
you're a documentary short like he did a
show every day for like six years at 6
p.m. just talking [__] yeah basically
doing a podcast everything live had 40
listeners still on that [__] still on
that [__] the work ethic of Joe exotic
is insane and ahead of his time he's
doing that ten years ago it's live
streaming that's crazy
I think Rogan he's the original Joe
Rogan yeah Joe exotic really it's crazy
yeah I wonder what they would talk about
it I bet they'd ever time to talk about
I hope he gets out man I think he's
gonna you know but here now here's the
thing if he got obsessed with one to
kill that lady I don't know if he did
cuz I did some research on that lady
okay
she talked about she's like I wish
because they wanted to Netflix want to
follow up with some of the people and
like show what they're doing now and she
was like it's weird because since I
worked for since I worked for PETA I
owned a big cat sanctuary she goes me
and Joe really like I didn't really deal
with him that much like he made it seem
like there was this whole thing against
me she was I Ted people that I was going
after he's just one of them Wow excited
a bunch going on it wasn't like I was
focused solely on him and he was that
really solely focused on me either she
goes but it's the document she might
seem that way huh she was like I had a
bunch of [__] going oh yeah definitely
killed her husband yeah but but do you
believe about that stuff though cuz I
like that lady to me seemed like and
that man that husband met new husband
man she had something's wrong with that
guy how about when he was like Lonnie
Baskin never leave you and you can never
leave anyway you're gonna end up in a
damn body bag Carl okay that picture of
him yeah just like a tiger and she had
him on like a leash on their web I
didn't see that on their wedding I fell
asleep during one of the episode
Carol bask and wedding yeah [__] was
always dressed up in some sort of animal
print - oh yeah I was the print of her
dead husband's finger prints on her body
now I can't get my will print any at
most collab Nike does and there's animal
print I pick them up I buy them but [__]
dude this [__] needs to relax look Joe
exactly I mean he people oh [__] unreal
unreal and that's your boy Lonnie Baskin
right there Lonnie basking yeah [__]
Barney rubbles [__] yeah that's that
but this don't fit they're all [__]
Carney trouble dude these guys are much
too [__] straight carnies out here
right that's what it seemed like it
seemed like somebody gave a couple
carnies a tiger and some money yeah and
this is what happens dude the shitty
part is is people like her or their do
when she's doing the same thing he would
do the exact same thing and cook down
yeah so you know he was making like 30
40 G's going to the malls showing kids
Tigers and [__] she's like nope not up
in here and shut that [__] down that's
why he hated her cuz he was like do I
need cover my nut by bringing these
Tigers to the mall no different than
what she does she just had people go to
her sanctuary he'd bring them to the
malls we get paid for
so she stopped that she's a [__]
hater she was a hater she's the one that
deserves 22 years and yeah dude and the
thing is also though they don't now
you're not gonna have these type of
places anymore that's one thing I don't
like there's a downside to all of that
the documentary and everything why cuz
we're gonna shut this kind of [__] down
now except for her but I shut this the
other thing here's what the go on the
other thing is is uh I would never be
that comfortable to [__] hang out
with Tigers and [__] I've never been
that cool oh yeah
never would you the [__] tiger really
your kids named Tiger you can't hang out
with a live tiger
what do you think he's gonna do dude
we're not going there we're gonna go on
what are you gonna do as soon as he can
[__] be away from you although he
might go don't think I think about the L
expected those places aren't a run no
exotic was a hustle don't know where you
got all that millions of dollars they
opened that [__] up and tigers we get a
few up in this [__] the only two grand
dude we have three walking around three
thousand dollars a year per tiger for to
feed him well not what not when they get
older though oh I don't know I thought
he was cutting corners I thought he was
like I got it down to three thousand
dollars they got a few cows well did you
hear what he was doing he getting that
Walmart me yeah and then also roadkill
yeah but it makes sense yeah Tigers
aren't like real you know you don't see
a tiger at the arm you know at the zoo
no you don't see one it like a nice
restaurant you know they don't care what
they eat you know I catch a tiger that's
Sizzlers yeah you might catch it I mean
Tiger would eat that [__] Shoney's if
it was open you know here's what though
debate set would they say
54% think he should be in prison 40% of
six percent say no well you that's a
hung jury though isn't it is that enough
uh you need unanimous in a jury so so
one I just need one out of twelve yeah
yeah just one twelve Angry Men yep so
you have to have you need you so he
would be free then all right free hung
jury yeah yeah he'd be free the other
thing is you know dr. rakes my heart man
me too cuz document but documentaries
all of them have they got to paint a
picture right right so I feel bad for
him but then when you talk about you
know homeboy who came in was shooting
all his [__]
was in the Hat I was in the coffee shop
I got see Hey Joe Hey Joe exotic [__]
hates them Hugh saying he's the most
evil person he's ever met in his life
but that guy also was kind of a [__]
nutcase did Rick Kirkham yeah he was
real tight I thought he was the [__]
Steven spielberger make million dollar
selling this thing yeah and he was
really kind of right I mean that that I
mean that sure would have been amazing
he it was on today after this let's say
Joe exotic was out of prison was doing
the show now that [__] would be popping
I mean watch it I bet Rick got paid cuz
he had all that footage he sold the
production no well he has learned and
some of that footage but yeah Joe exotic
burned it all down I've only seen the
first three episodes that's the thing
about Joe you can't cross him bro well
here's any more necessary than down ice
it was gangster man anyway he was doing
it for his brother his brother commit
suicide he was like this dedication my
brother and [__] built this Empire
yeah but it also makes me it's like he
would just he always used everything as
a thing you know I mean I guess that's
life you know but it's some time and a
certain point I just started off where
didn't I don't trust you think
something's going I don't I don't let
anybody feature on the document I don't
like the drug-induced homosexuality
you know it's hardly enough if
somebody's on drugs and then you slip
them a dick you know behind a behind a
pipe
I'm not gonna lie that Joe exotic talked
a mean game I I don't want to go down
I'm scared about having myself that
Oklahoma boy drove down and play with
some Tigers you know he's married
what am I gonna do bro he did that every
toy you would want bro you want a gun
you want a tiger you want this what you
want my TV yes what do you wanna do I
Drive my wiener with your tongue I guess
so Joe can i play with the Tigers after
yeah dude you shoot enough bullets
Pettit Aki you don't even know if you
got a dick on you I don't we know it's
great it's crazy
yeah they see you know that's straight
for you yeah it's great I mean you could
fall any throw a little bit of drugs in
there with guns and cats and big heads
you surround me with Tigers I seen your
dick sound what are we doing at the
petting zoo man petting with my face bro
yes it could get real crispy up
whoa oh I'll tell you don't bring around
exotic Joe Broz petting zoo staff
grizzly man I like tiger King a lot
better when it was called grizzly man
that was way better yeah yeah he liked
lived with on the Bears oh that man was
up there playing with the Bears yeah
that may got eaten alive he was no
entrepreneur you know he got even a lot
of oh yeah and they had that bad -
recording oh I gotta send you this I
gotta send you this this dude oh I saw
that yesterday did Eddie send it to with
the bear attack is that real yeah Brogan
said it's real it looks for you this
dude they're out in the last hunting
beers and this beer went cool story bro
that's your face hey Josh I'm a Senate
DNA goon very ruin my night wait do you
see this watch it I want you guys to
feel what I felt it's daytime yes
daytime they ruin my night daytime I'm
Jay like many it came in here I'll be
watching crazy shoes I'm Teddy sent to
Rogen
and Brian I do that this group sent some
alarming [__] you never know what that'd
be hella honest he posted my number on
one of his IG TV video IG TV videos he
did that a screen record of the ron paul
and my number popped up BAM be saved and
I got like 50 random tax from psycho
Eddie fans thank you yeah all they were
Thomas flatters trying to convert you to
flatters I got a lot of that one me my
got a big black guy's dick and then a
lot of Jeffrey Epstein the big black
guys dick is really taken over him there
are you guys getting it in a a culture
corner you guys getting it at all
I heard he's dead though oh really yeah
oh yeah cuz he's not yeah I want to book
him on this past weekend yeah oh you do
we wanted to instead you got big big
well keep researching Davis coming in
dude which ironically was the man's
nickname for his penis he's yeah you
could put at LSU condom on it what do
you got can't wait were you guys getting
that a lot of that black Weiner man
going around yeah somebody photoshopped
a screenshot of last week's episode with
Chappelle and I and the Photoshop [__]
fell out and put him there let me ask
you this who's a bigger Corona lockdown
MVP the Weiner man or [__] Joe exotic
I'd say Joe exotic cuz that's seven
hours of quality content yeah yeah who's
a bigger what at the MVP you know cuz
there's some MVPs as corona lock oh okay
Corona and B think that's a good debate
who's who's kind of the real MVP here
I'd say Joe exotic hmm I feel like big
black dick the last forever yeah how
dare you I feel like Joe exotic last
forever I think we could get him out of
prison you thinkin [__] yeah but what's
a petition gonna be I think you got
screwed over man I think you got screwed
over man this is just it's so heavy to
go into it yeah [__] guy with the
bootleg lemur you believe that any
rolled on everyone no can we talk about
the hips Gary talked about the hit man
who's too lazy to go to Florida got
halfway there like not for me turn
around
hold up he agreed to murder a person
because he was too lazy turn around that
guy's free yeah but he was down to
murder what about him you tell me he's
worse than Joey exotic it's crazy it
makes you wonder if if karma like does
really
that's what it made for me MIT was like
where's the car now how does it really
work here because if the lady did kill
her husband Joe brought a lot of it on
himself no man he went after that man he
went after that woman he would not leave
her alone he's down there with the
rabbit head on and the dumb [__] put
snakes in her mailbox yeah man and it's
telling you got to shut it down [__] was
dope yeah just send somebody in actually
find out what's going on what do you got
me I have a debate club for you kiss or
ac/dc who do you got let me know Gang
Gang buzz buzz kiss already DC can I
hear some of their [__] classics huh
ac/dc Oh hells bells welcome to the
jungle
this is kiss know that that's
everything's been ac/dc so far that
we've said what wait was he say kisser
ac/dc yeah ac/dc man gene Simmons
honestly seems like a [__] [__] to
me I feel like gene Simmons is one
[__] bad [__] drug away from being
one of joe exotic boys always had that
face paint on and [__] and the high
heels not fooling nobody broke yeah I
interviewed his daughter one time she
was less than desirable to be around her
a few times
she's a dying me though mm she's [__]
Wooden Nickel yes I don't know man I
wouldn't give you two cents for her
attitude that's for sure
but what do I know you know I'm just an
accomplished young man with a [__]
nice [__] exactly now you said you do
got a nice [__] God made that straight I
want to beat that the Obama exactly for
any reason to make you gay oh how many
letters easy suddenly gonna be getting
in prison dude but he still has that
boyfriend Dylan what's his name
whatever that boy's name is that boy was
in that Camaro SS crying he called three
times a day
God don't worry I can get it out of here
we we can be together
he said I know baby crying these gay
boys man it's a real love story really
really gay though that's the question
yeah they are you think yeah dude I
don't like how you won't admit that that
man is full on my homoerotic I think he
is just lost and troubled man in
drug-induced man you do enough drugs you
end up gay man I talk about it all the
time as facts
give me some kiss what kiss best song
what's the number-one song because I'm
not that big of a kiss fan boy doing too
much makeup for me
joins artists more straight than kiss
kiss was just more I agree with that
kiss was more what is the kids out what
you say kiss hit yeah I don't know ac/dc
destroys kiss by the way yeah kiss ain't
even close
here's my ass bro dick what else is
going on oh dude I freaking had the
worst gas earlier today - would you eat
uh I don't know I haven't really had a
lot of stuff to eat recently you're just
lighten it up yeah I know I just felt it
in my body so I went to I have a buddy
that does is his guy that was by me is
almost like a he like kind of like it's
almost like a kind of like a
chiropractor like if you had bad gas and
you're like [__] and adjust your body so
you don't have it oh yeah yeah pretty
[__] wild actually and it worked
yeah really yeah when you're lighting
your apartment uh-huh you're lighting it
up uh no there was no volume - it was
just real quiet yes like a drone you
forget you did it silently just very
calm like somebody tiptoeing out of
Europe but somebody playing with
slippers on his chip toner idea but with
it's like doing with aqua Sox on buddy
dude he put you he does look this thing
with your leg
like super day but we crack your back
dude he'll adjust the gas right out of
you dude it's crazy and now I feel great
dude
yeah I feel totally no pressure from the
inside of my body that's nice
oh I'll peep that dude out what's just
this is my brother j4 is his name little
guy too it's almost like letting a
monkey get on your body when he [__]
fixes oh he'll [__] fix the gas right
out of you do remarkable is that lemur
hair you guys do a lot of that don't you
chin with the different types of yeah
agent culture you a lot of Eastern
medicine yeah I don't think about I
don't know about gas though that gas
jacker you got to get a dude it'll just
jack the gas right out here's a couple
of correct Chester yeah I don't know it
sounds super home oh yeah whoa
do you practice Eastern medicine oh do
you practice Western medicine gin do you
believe in one more than the other I
tried that acupuncture once I really
gave it a shot yeah but then the doctor
left one needle stuck in my chest when I
put my shirt back on
and then it's stuck in me after that day
I'll never go back to chiropractor oh
yeah I know I wouldn't go back one
needle in me oh I'll never go back
that's unprecedented I feel like it has
to happen to other people I've never
heard of it I've got a ton of
acupuncture how did you get those the
cup sucking I know I need to do that
though so that's probably one easier
medicine that I'll try it cuz everyone
seems to believe in it that should help
yeah but usually it's Western medicine
yeah Thank You lers I'm trying to get
over to Eastern man and he did say
painkillers Indian so you got some too
no I wish hey guys ganking buzz buzz
this is Ben from Boise I know Ben's hi
you guys he's handsome who is worse at
texting back Bryan Callen or Bobby Lee I
keep seeing I know they're [__] both
oldest [__] boys trying to hear what you
guys say don't the [__] going on my
hair look like Jimmy Neutron [__] back
out but like 60 years younger
love to hear back from you guys thank
you guys much love ganking buzz-buzz
yeah yeah gang bra right yeah yeah did
the last time you talked to your
grandparents you don't really know how
to wrap up the call you know I sometimes
my service goes out and just hang up at
all
Orion takes back pretty well yeah it's
easily Bobby Lee's the worst
Bobby Lee for sure I hear that he's
getting better but no one I've ever met
never met a worse communicator than
Robert Lee yeah yeah Robert oh yeah will
not reach out for every years I mean he
drives he doesn't even he plays that
game candy crush well he drives his car
like full-on
crush right and driving yeah it's
unbelievable he said his car's automat
or whatever it is like it's a it'll get
you there or whatever press yeah that's
not a test it's a pretty [__] Prius
yeah and he's hit like 70 things doc
it's the dark arts man definitely Bobby
the last two percent yeah Brian I'm
pretty good at that Brian is really even
call sometime you know Juanita Brian's
pretty good at returning right yeah I
feel like what's up Theo Macho Man Randy
average and Brendan punishes gay twin
brother what's more likely to pull the
ladies playing the guitar or playing the
piano the piano you need the boy Hendrix
versus Billy dope the the Angus young
versus we've got another dude that plays
the p.m. personally I think it's the
guitar carries what you think
gangrene buzz aldrin I love this kid I
met Buzz Aldrin once did you and he look
like he hadn't been to the moon man
believe him when I looked in his eyes
and I've said this before when I looked
in his eyes he didn't look like somebody
who'd been to the moon now let's let's
just let the listeners know you also
don't think joe exotic is gay so take it
for what for what it's worth that boy's
[__] career and [__] Topanga
Canyon definitely curve you're gay Susie
ass yeah
Joe exotic I think he's gay but I think
he's I think it's converting them
straight boys I think that's hard to do
and again the work ethic bro he's
relentless myocyte all right just do it
dude they can upload Tigers after just
doing it he's a Lance Armstrong of gays
mm-hmm unstoppable leader everybody was
[__] over Tigers he just did it
better
dude I know this video you know he heard
his like he shot himself in the [__]
leg dude Oh that'd be great if they had
that video and I bet after that he just
used it as a every now and then if [__]
went haywire he would just shoot himself
in the [__] leg to get attention yeah
oh yeah I'll do it but it was great when
he started just firing that pistol yeah
in a studio your balls that [__] you
doing cops would come good luck getting
through the Tigers yeah how about when
they're like we're gonna shut you down I
said good luck in through I'm what
waving this white flag you have to kill
me get me out of here with my Tigers
like [__] yeah Joe that's crazy
man was brave there was a lot going on
man what about when they open that
pizzeria with them meat from the Walmart
truck just a real businessman who just
stellar I'd invest in that zoo oh yeah
now that's a zoo I go in on Newt if we
started at pet petting zoo
with Joe exotic heavy a pet can make
animals you can imagine how to pray
dude we just invested and marketed for
him yeah [__]
he calls in over the PA system from
prison out of y'all yeah yo wait daddy
definitely guitars oh that's an easy man
guitars that panty-dropper pianos that
[__] booty drop burn I think it used
to be a panty-dropper I think now it's
definitely piano more I think the guitar
we're getting back anymore the piano
times John Legend had something to do
with that but then dude you see a
[__] nice young man ripping on that
[__] just shred City I'll be joy
exotic in that [__] just like what you
got a tiger next year dude I'm suck it
what do you guys think let's go to the
culture corner and get some talk really
yeah
you forget mixtape it's not a mixtape is
that she was straight mixtape did you
get a deal I recorded off GarageBand did
you get a did you get a record deal well
I had to get it back first and then to
get the record deal but I don't have one
yeah yeah still shopping it around
gems a musician what do you think guitar
[__] piano well I've played both for
girls in front of girls and guarantee
it's the guitar cuz the piano usually
fits piano you're facing the wall
alright if it's in a house oh yeah put
that [__] on top it's hard your face
right in front of them and look in their
eyes and sing yeah be conjoined yeah no
look at me chin you'd like this if
you're already on the piano then that
means I don't have to do anything yo Dee
yeah my girl yeah I used to play a piano
at night for Mom I don't have to play
alright I could see you I could see you
on the piano or guitar thank you
you can play both - I'm better at guitar
breaking playbook yeah she's super
talented
you also start a [__] band that's
what I'm saying me and feeling market it
yeah we did you call it rush hour
[Laughter]
like yeah and Nick and rap on it well we
all know Nick's around I feel bad for he
hurt his neck rapping that's you know
how he knows you he win in yeah what do
you think Kat from a few in perspective
what if you're dating some dude can you
come over here as a piano laid out or he
has a [__] guitar he's like what's up
girl obviously drives a tow truck it's
got the piano is that laid out some of
those floor pianos burning that like you
don't ball oh well he this the other
thing forgetting to you could have one
of those electric pianos keep his just
in his lap beats were horrible dude that
solves a shins problem he can look in
the eyes that way if you just got that
small one true but they got to plug it
in somewhere I get batteries battery you
gotta plug that guitar in whose Allegro
goes to stick I love about that John
Mayer yeah always acoustic not a lecture
dude girl gets that John Mayer
she has a classic [__] guitar tits out
do I mean that's wifey crazy yeah
brother
probably what do cats a yeah you have to
go with guitar because if one I think a
keyboard look silly like if it do
brought out keyboard and started doing
everything like friend friend zone not
necessarily I do don't want to go out
with ya keyboard we'll get you into the
friend zone ya know it's kind of hard to
bring around anywhere it's like you're
trying a little bit but if a guy pushes
it over brings it over with his car
pulls it over he's sweating has to
cutoff jean shorts what
sorry Joe exotic hair yo exotic nope but
up but also if a dude's playing the
piano it's super intimate too if you
seem like some John Legend like all of
you like it's real serious but you can't
have fun on the on the [__] piano
guitar you get loose man Stevie Wonder
has Vanya he's the greatest musician of
all time yeah you could take your legs
on dude
Vienna will make you feel like you could
take your damn legs off dude yeah so
just you live yeah imagine that dude you
could see and then suddenly the music so
good you just go [__] belong praise
God [__] yeah what does guy wanna know
King and so we we said guitar everybody
seems like easily what was the vote on
that I'm gonna roll piano man [__] no I
wish I could play either though well can
you play any instrument have you ever
tried yeah I used to play a guitar a
little bit and I and I've played the
piano I can play the piano okay if I
have music in front of me
did somebody teach you or you just pick
them I just learned at home just well
you're creative dude books they're
pretty easy it's not that hard you just
have to have a lot of time and you gotta
have read some real patients you had a
real gift when I was playing rock band
did you dude I don't know what it was I
just felt like a me my boys get together
I was on them drums
dude I felt like [__] flee on that
[__] I just see you in the drums Travis
Barker
I can see you doing drugs so like a
drummer I would love to be a drummer
yeah I'll have my shirt off I put that
[__] bandanna and a flag around your
necktie African American flag yeah like
a choke collar and then a bandana shirt
off sweat and just stock on your neck
yeah yeah that too and that's what they
did it's Lee you gotta go harder they be
awesome
and you play the bass yeah Noel could
you basement okay you seem you could
handle the bass right chin you should
cover when those Joe exotic tune I'm
thinking about it the one that you
posted I like actually like the song
have you're doing where he saw him out
killing the lady feeling the Tigers did
not hear though oh he has like it he has
like
as actress not being her first spot on
its a banger my god
what's it called yo exotic joke's on you
exotic God he had some no not here
kitty-kitty for me bro but imagine
you're he's in his car you listening to
his music just never the whirlpool of
himself he was in never ended brother he
never came up for air he had too much
[__] no house oh this is right here that
lady looked just like her to do a
stupid-ass outfit
dude oklahomans my bucket is good man
praise God do the Mustang Oklahoma's
like a Ferrari lady my god euthanize
this yours a rich woman she had rich
taste the blood that's a cloud dress
bubble
she liked the life she had she loved big
cats and the view
Oh
[Music]
sweetest wine butter you do this chin
pretty like the other one I'm not
feeling this one not my course wait for
the course because that [__] beat
drops yeah but you feel that penny a
chess player if we remade this dish with
all the King's Speech
[Music]
love the songs better Jim yes is that
the question
yeah that's so slow here's some other
things too that was tough because it's
out of spite
[Laughter]
it only has a quarter million lessons
man I agree but I wonder who even owns
the rights to his music and stuff now I
wonder if he knows that my first love
dude the [__] hits hard was it oh this
is a slapper we're never get melody are
these
oh just a friend that's assessment still
be a boy straight
soon my phone is this course broke it
looks just a busy North Woods I don't
know
close your eyes this is a gay Garth
Brooks should I write maybe take the
chance
Moke let's go last fall the road
you still stranded I don't like that
line little heartbreaker rest of its
really that little [__] death trap
and there he comes dude here comes this
little twink or Belle no I'm really
surprised all even boys
I bet in the snow a bit subtle snow
leopards bro man I bet he would balance
a little meth rock the end of his wiener
sometimes you know I'm surprised
Joe exact never made a sex tape with his
boys you're surprised he did it yeah you
want a hobo you want famous so bad he'll
release somebody
the man that's on the right wouldn't
happen to it a lot of gay men always act
like they're playing hide-and-go-seek
[Music]
we're at Arby's if we're not even we
drove here together drove together dude
he's sitting in our beak you know what I
don't like and we can shut this down now
what I don't like here about this is
it's all him every every saying is him
it's just the start
bro yeah but if you too much of the
story you just you can't uphold it all
man you can't do all that I feel like
man maybe I'm being negative a better
Oklahoman him Joe exotic or [__]
Jason white the Heisman Trophy winner if
you have to kill one probably kill Jason
White well Joe's already in jail Jason
still has a life to live maybe I don't
know what he's doing
Jason has a family maybe I'm shocked
that Joe didn't have any children with
any women just to have you know just
have another Linea I think his Tigers
were his lineage I bet he was sterile
you know nobody was a sterile man and
maybe that's why he was coming in these
fellows because he was sterile you know
you got to think about everything
Brendan okay what I know is hope I can
reach for you some days and not all the
time you're doing a lot you're doing
better but [__] you know you work hard
let's get out of this thing what's this
guy feel like everybody says it's just
like should I drink or drive or not
that's what all these look see your king
is drunk driving this will close out
with some relationship advice
oh hell yeah I do I Brennan this is
Arthur come to you all the way from
Massachusetts first of all love the show
yeah Meatwad thank you guys for what you
do but I'm looking for dating advice so
right now somebody that I work with is
trying to set me up with one of his very
close friends which already I'm a little
hesitant because I don't want to make
things weird between me and him
right um or things weird in the office
but I also not sure that me and his
friend are right people for each other
and here's what so she is apparently an
ex-marine
she's a self-described
dedicated redneck and
recently I guess she had to be held back
at a party from beating the [__] out of
someone so I guess she's uh she got an
attitude which oh-hoo wrong girl he just
goes on to say he's more peaceful chill
guy might be a little yin and yang hmm
she might yet it sounds very dangerous I
think you should go for the ride oh yeah
I can save it Private Ryan dude you get
in there dude [__] what's wrong with
dating GI Jane maybe you called to some
mud
yeah so you get your dick sucked dude
it's a good time yeah that's true it
could be real outdoorsy it could be um
it seems like I don't know if you're
already nervous about it she's gonna
sense that man and probably pounce on
and I feel like you know she might beat
you up yeah she sounds very tough I
don't wanna you know it's hard if you're
trying to like like feel a chick up and
her tits are real hard
yeah it's also hard if you're trying to
feel that she's a huge [__] didn't say
[__] at all that we don't know it sounds
like she's real aggressive she has a
beard if all we know it's the only fact
he gave us I'm just piecing things
together trying to help homeboy out man
oh yeah my bad we're trying to help him
out I think you go on a date with GI
Jane see how it goes and keep us posted
dude yes I know some military chicks
dude there's
some of the baddest women the earth you
know I'm saying I ain't talking about
them shooting [__] Isis I'm talking
about some just baddies yeah underneath
that camouflage some [__] hush
puppies hmm yeah they got some real real
sweet gals out there in the military and
I'll say this also dude you sound like a
nice guy you seem like somebody that's
nice you know you're able to drive you
have two arms I saw in the video you're
a healthy guy good video clear yeah
you're working somewhere you're employed
got a chin yeah and now you're gonna
risk it all for GI Jane for whatever
yeah whatever Rambo you know this female
Rambo ran bit rambling a date with Ram
bell and keep his [__] posted dude
it's like he's scared man he's gonna be
in a neck brace she's gonna [__] he's
gonna throw a grenade in a second yeah
her her way of foreplay is waterboarding
you dude I made love to a woman one time
down there in Guantanamo Bay down there
and uh she had a grenade yeah in the
trunk of her car and she said well go
off I don't know let's do this she just
it was cool man it's nice to you know
it's nice to have a grenade around die
hard baby and you're meeting somebody
it's interesting it's fun so I think
there's a good opportunity there to meet
somebody that's really exciting but I
don't want you to see you get hurt man I
think you ought to the nation she served
four years for your [__] freedom I
was talking suck on a tip yeah a little
piece of [__] hook up with Ron betta and
let us know - yeah when you put it like
that man get out there and freakin
salute them what did you do for the
country yeah get up there salute that
broad brother you got this man good luck
out there
sorry father it looks like my English
teacher this is well last one King under
sting Ellison beautiful tip right then
watermelons are shaken bro I love it
already
Theo this is Alison from Florida I have
a little keener stinger for you
beautiful hair so me and my friend Lee
just laid off due to the coronavirus off
Tommy is a hairdresser I'm a cast member
at Walt Disney World and so we've been
googling like different ways to make
money at home and it's all and one of
the ways we found was to sell your
panties online and we thought it might
be a great idea
maybe name our store the cookie jar who
knows no College Street dude coffee
business streets and you guys just sell
undies Rodriques is a very uni I think
you're limiting your audience there's
some women there's people that just want
a warm piece of panties in the mail yeah
it's not a bad idea I think they should
start a business called streaks and then
start fans only calm also I can't
believe [__] khloe kardashian if I
can do the kicker sting look I think
yeah they'll a this is obviously the
lady from frozen robe and uh you could
easily sell your panties to somebody you
know I think you could even just start
local do Craig's lesser you know if you
don't want to open up the full Shopify I
also so think you can [__] so
pictures them tears she's trying to do a
legal business you free you can do that
legally sell panties called streaks and
[__] oil up them tits and sell it
dude there's a huge business out there
[Laughter]
that's that dark dark hush puppies get
them out make some money girl I mean I
have to look if you feel like going to
that extent I think you'll learn by
starting off with just the panties you
may be seeing what other things you
could put in the cart and I stand by
streets I stand by streaks call it
streaks man yeah yeah stand by that I'd
invest in it
what do you think ship hell you gonna
throw some bread on the internet for
some tits or for some pain have you ever
done anything like that I've ever bought
under women's underwear anything
coughing uh
I've never done anything like that I've
sniffed some underwear okay really I'm
not into there that's normal
hae-jin in Asia catch isn't there
vending machines no chance yeah I do
well I don't know if they're streets
there but there's use panties and yeah
job yeah you know did you know that like
you know we can get [__] KitKat's and
[__] pretzels you can get streak
undies in Japan mmm I like it I wouldn't
mind if you're having a tough day or
something you pull over grab a cup grab
a parent just huh fun while you're
driving along the interstate yeah and
you wonder where they got Corona you
know I'm saying dude can't be smell
smelling [__] undies all day yeah
you're right all smells fresh sneakers
though you got them sneakers say I'll
get high off those right now yeah yeah
look at that dude get you a pair of
undies out of that vending machine get
your little panty bra and some people
wear a panty on their head till you see
it sometime burglar now there's another
thing you could do sell burglar attire
that's true quit Bergling in that same
old [__] you know saying get out there
and these be in these scented hitters
that robbers dude yeah okay rots ahead
of the time
oh you right you were some hey hoes all
the time attention blows is shoot just
cousin in the chest yeah good luck girl
is he man we got an interview him can we
do can we think we can do a Skype with
him next week absolutely he di means the
other day cuz he was gonna come by
Toronto show and he said I think it got
canceled brother yeah I can well this is
a beautiful young lady and I think you
look you could probably sell 40 pairs to
people that watch this show so I think
you guys should do it good luck girl and
what's a good price you think cat if
somebody's gonna sell like their panties
and I'm not asking cuz I would think you
know I'm just saying you're the only
female in here if you legit we're gonna
suggest to this lady a price what do you
think I think it depends on each person
like it really depends on who's willing
if someone's willing to buy it for $50
or $100 that's just market value I think
$19.99 sounds pretty
fair this one I don't want to double
whatever you pay for the pants crazy
Brendon well I don't know how much your
panties I don't know at least depends on
where you get them just give me like a
normal like a twenty thirty secret
Victoria secretly have a five for
twenty-eight deal five for twenty eight
and I sell each pair for $19.99 mm-hmm
okay but I think I twenty dollars if I'm
gonna get I feel like if I'm paying for
something like that I'm willing to pay
$40 I'm willing to pay fifty dollars I
don't want that $20 pair of you want
that $20 Street kiddo also if you don't
realize this shipping involved to $4.99
for shipping I see no yeah $100 d you
really okay see it all together in your
market no do they bottle it them first
that's a good point you get a picture
window minimum now if you throw in that
photograph I think you're talking next
for ten fifteen dollars now you're
taught you got that combo pack where you
wear it and you got your tits out oiled
up
I'll pay nice 49.99 also don't limit
yourself use your socks too
yeah people like some people like feet
and some of the scent is gonna go away
in the mail that's the problem with the
mayor you lose half the sense in the
mail now if you spray a little of that
perfume on vacuum-seal yeah I think if
you vacuum-sealed on now you're talking
so now I think you can get up into the
$80 range
thank you see you more overhead - so you
gotta go higher but but see now you know
you make you make our trip to the post
office in a day you drop off for payers
you're clearing 50 dollars a pair after
all your expenses streaks are us 200
bundle made worse name though I'm gonna
vote no one makes our own what would be
a good name a land I'm just sayin but
the bad name I'm not saying you're a bad
guys you know like streets I don't like
I'm not buying something from streaks
are us Underpants women super soakers is
very interesting the names taken by the
water gun yeah maybe that's a good one
good one
yeah what would be a good name streak
scratchy scoops
I like oh yeah I just like it different
I like that maybe scoops panty Emporium
oops
yeah scoop it up dog scoop it up or the
panty
shanty what about that panty shack yeah
panty panty shot what else man panty
panty time
panty time there you go
and it's an intern o'clock and it just
shows panties on the top no watches now
to expect no watches black pant ether
and it's like a it's like you have a
different darker panties we're gonna
play on Victoria's Secret mmm okay
Oh Victoria Peak written is a little bit
of urine and that's gross no I like that
I don't like it let's discuss I still
like streaks I really think it's gonna
catch on i streaks streaks are
unaffected streets to me sounds like
dirty underwear
that's how cute that's what you mean
yeah this I mean maybe they do I've
never done it I've never bought it
you're right what do you guys think
nikkor chain you guys seem like somebody
look maybe invest in something like
pandemonium or like how do you say
pandemonium panty mo diem pants imodium
yeah yeah imodium is a diarrhea drug yes
about pay that Piper's panty pipers
painting diapers I like that Paul's
panty Piper's yeah like that
Paul's panty tech pay what was her name
it's gonna help me you were charged for
a crimson Alison
Nelson's panty Emporium that's all we
got today - Alison's
Alison's ant eaters Alison's she had a
friend who was doing it to Lois Florida
I have a little keener sting it for you
so me and my friend were both recently
just laid off dude okay they're laid off
so um she played a Disney character oh
yes she was a Disney her dad I wish she
told us which one I bet it's gotta be
frozen huh I don't know why you keep
thinking she's [__] frozen dude
there's only thing she's implying
there's two women in from hey Doc
there's two women in frozen right and
who are the women in frozen Elsa and
Elsa yeah she could easily be one of
those women have you seen the cartoon
yeah okay maybe froze Oh thawed out Bob
out thoughts yeah thought out thought
where yeah thought where yeah calming
thoughts
what about thoughts are us ooh now we're
talking what if you did panties from
different female characters Cinderella's
panties Beauty and the Beast a nice
little pansy yeah pieces covered and
[__] it's the Beast undies baling [__]
across the mail you can't do that well I
need a few other facts I'm thinking
China Asia that's what like yeah you
smell a panty Brian nobody wants duty in
the pan okay so do tease out those
details before we started this
brainstorm they want a scent of a woman
they don't want like a sick woman you
know is it duty-free Goods dude came in
FedEx and turds
he wasn't catching our hints the whole
time no Brendan well these are details I
needed before we start this whole
brainstorming operation yeah maybe I'll
use underwear yeah
I think duty-free maybe maybe duty-free
and some at the airport you're limiting
your [__] demo there man some guys
kill you once a surprise we have shell
companies we have duty-free and duty
full I need to know what Disney
character she plays to be decided how
about this let's do all I have people
submit for next week just some names of
good names for companies for a female
that wants to sell underpants and I also
follow up well let's see what Disney
character shoes that's gonna help us
yeah if they had any more Intel but yeah
if people want to send in some ideas for
names appropriate names nothing too
nasty at a yawn bro cuz I guess they
reposition that gasps oh wow it's got to
come out and feel good oh yeah I feel
great bro it was a real Ripper that it
Nick
that's it Wow God well praise God for
this show got us out of the house
they're on a time I know you're not
supposed to be meeting up with people on
this we're definitely really uh this
real bootleg gonna and we have a loose
definition of six feet yeah I mean you
guys behind why when I go out and
chapelle about six feet the only ones
gonna worry about a the two of us it's
Bravo bish and you know supposed to be
hanging out with your Bros take a
speakeasy but stay safe out there guys I
guess our Pia is it getting worse or
better do you guys know what what are
you guys hearing Kat Chappelle I just
got a bunch of mixed information I don't
know what staff the newsman yeah I can't
your haters what are your parents
telling you guys nothing text me woman
I've heard from my dad either
damn I worse I sent him that John with
the big dick my dad stopped
communicating with me yeah that he'll do
it and then I and then I tried to give
him invest in streaks and he wouldn't
I can imagine how he feels
can't what your folks saying not much my
mom just wants me to make sure that I'm
staying at home as much as possible but
that's about it
we don't really know anything hey did
you get people upset with us with the
Crone episode we did with Eddie and Sam
no it on the calendar you guys this is a
real condition you guys do to look up
your facts more like [__] are you out
your goddamn mind
you came to King in the state for I hope
you get corroded there's the one thing
that we can definitely King is that we
are not a viable news source for the
last 30 minutes I've been trying to
[__] [__] here another thing Joe
exotic is gay all over the map I think
the jury is still out is what I'm
against and I think the jury's closed
this this is not a cold case that man's
[__] as curvy as Topanga Canyon and
whoa look let's put on there on also on
the IG if we can get people to vote on
um if you gay or drug-induced gay just
gay in the summer soirée here cuz
there's a difference between just being
gay and being pipe gay you know like
sometimes it is true it's true bro
sometimes it's seasonal flares
coronavirus it flares up six feet away
to meet a fella all right streets are
are sold I take care of your
grandparents
with the sunshine in
all the crowds that came in can't
believe
[Music]
oh and all the goodies here stay all the
reasons I
[Music]
see
because you
cuz you
[Music]